and Kill Bill when you have Michael
Parks playing Esteban yeah yeah I did
not know that that wasn't a Mexican guy
well that's an actually an interesting
story about how that came about because
you know Michael Parks is actually one
of my favorite actors so we always have
a big a big day in our movies is when I
had the the script reading because
that's like the closest to me actually
seeing the movie finished maybe not
everybody is there so like oh hey you
take this role hey uh you read this one
I had actually had cast Ricardo
Montalban to play Esteban and he
couldn't make it so Michael was there
because he was uh playing the Texas
Ranger so he did the Texas Ranger and
then I threw something else at him and
threw something else at him and then I
go hey Mike would you take would you
play Esteban because yeah sure and he
did such a fantastic Esteban stole the
show it was just great so we paid off uh
Ricardo montemon and I uh I cast Michael
instead that's gotta suck to get that
call
well his ass should have been at the
[ __ ] table
you know if he had some place better to
be then uh well we have some place
better to be too